[Music]
what's up guys michael here in an
undisclosed location to talk about the
movie that dared to ask what if you met
another version of yourself and they
were kind of a dick obviously we're
talking about doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness despite a long
history of trying and failing to put the
surgeon turned wizard on the big screen
doctor strange has been a marvel
favorite since benedict cumberbatch
brought him to life in 2016. since he's
climbed the ranks of the avengers and
sort of saved the world and the new film
did not disappoint it's packed with
trippy visuals exciting wizard fights
and genuinely moving emotional arcs but
is something deeper going on when
strange and newcomer america chavez
traversed the multiverse can wandas
completely bonkers plan to recreate her
perfect family actually teach us
something fundamental about the human
experience let's explore in this
wisecrack quick take the philosophy of
doctor strange and you know spoilers
ahead the core of this multiversal
madness revolves around the competing
supernatural forces of doctor strange
and wanda who has fully embraced her
scarlet witch identity the two have
opposite motivations wanda wants to
steal america's multiverse traveling
powers thus killing her strange wants to
save his new friend at all costs and
stop wanda's violent witchy rampage see
wanda is haunted by dreams of the
children she created back in west view
and because dreams are actually the
experiences of other use in the
multiverse which means a multiverse
version of me regularly pees his pants
she's tormented by the fact that every
other wanda seems to have a
picture-perfect life as a mom so she
hatches a plan to steal america's powers
to travel to a multiverse where she has
kids this also means she'd have to kill
another version of herself but she seems
to have not totally thought that part
through what's more having america's
ability to go to every iteration of the
universe means that if her kids get sick
or say have trouble getting into a top
tier college she can travel around the
multiverse and find novel medicines or a
really great s.a.t tutor and again kill
a version of herself she tries to
persuade strange to go along with her
plan but he refuses and rallies all of
comtaj to protect america wanda it seems
can outpower just about any living being
but she can't magic her way into
motherhood and then there's doctor
strange who after arguably saving the
world still has to sit by and watch the
love of his life christine marry some
other guy she even reminds him that you
always have to be the one holding the
knife that is to say he is a total
control freak the film opens with an
alternate strange in america running
from a demon having lost their lead
strange steals america's powers which he
knows will kill her rather than yielding
them to a monstrous force he's down to
take control of the situation even if it
means doing a murder though luckily the
demon murks him before he murks america
and throughout the film strange tries to
control everything he desperately tries
to stop wanda's antics axes america's
caretaker acquires the book of vashanti
and so on like wanda he even tries out
the dangerous new sport of dreamwalking
to control of all things his very own
decaying corpse we've got zombies in the
mcu folks but after a magic induced
massacre strange is faced with the
frightening reality that he might not be
able to control wanda's fury or save
america so here we have an interesting
miriam effect where our protagonist and
antagonist actually have the exact same
problem and in case you missed it it's
neatly summed up in the trailer by
sorcerer supreme wong you can't control
everything strange in contrast we have
america who maintains that she cannot
control her power to travel the
multiverse it only manifests when she's
scared unlike strange and wanda she's
keenly aware that many things are out of
her control so how can we make sense of
strange and wanda's shared desire for
control well with the help of our
favorite danish walking enthusiast soren
kierkegaard and guys i get it i talk
about him all the time but i went into
an unpayable amount of grad school debt
to learn about him so i gotta milk this
for all it's worth now in kierkegaard's
book repetition he tells a comedic tale
of a young man who was trying to
recreate or repeat a nice trip he took
to berlin because it made him so happy
at the time he goes back and stays at
the same place visits the same theater
hangs at the same coffee shop still the
initial magic is gone and none of these
experiences are as meaningful as they
were the first time and this isn't too
dissimilar from wanda's desire to
recreate or repeat the experience she
had as a mother though in fairness
kierkegaard's character wasn't trying to
kill a hip teen with superpowers one of
the ways that wanda attempts to do this
is to use dreamwalking to literally
occupy the body of another wanda in the
multiverse one who is calmly enjoying
her suburban life with her two boys but
during this experience our wanda seems
oddly out of sync and unable to connect
with this other version of herself and
for that matter with the children she
seemingly loves so much kierkegaard
describes something similar in
repetition eventually after doing
everything possible to repeat his
beloved trip the young man in berlin
realizes that there really isn't such a
thing as literal repetition and in
attempting to repeat the experience a
contradiction arises the conflict
between his ideal for how the trip would
feel and what it actually feels like in
reality the attempted repetition left
him with this feeling of contradiction
and or impossibility and we see this
when scarlet witch wanda literally comes
face to face with suburban mom wanda and
her kids everything she's done has been
motivated by wanting to once again
experience the love she had for her boys
when she finally sees them again they
are absolutely [ __ ] terrified of her
in this moment she experiences a
shattering disconnect between the ideal
of once again being a mother and the
reality of these kids thinking she's
super scary and that's the comic and in
this case tragic irony of repetition for
kierkegaard in trying to repeat
experiences we ultimately confront the
absolute impossibility of repetition put
differently and trying to control our
future we realize that total control is
impossible kierkegaard wrote in his
journals that life can only be
understood backwards but it must be
lived forward meaning that we should
learn from our past experiences instead
of trying to uncritically repeat them
ultimately wanda stops trying to control
the world around her and instead
destroys the darkhold so that nobody
might ever be tempted by its evils again
our guy dr strange has a similar
realization in the film though he's not
trying to recreate anything per se he
still wants things to go his way this
has been his move throughout his
appearances in the mcu he's kind of a
cocky prick and he's not the only one
throughout the film he encounters other
strangers from across the multiverse
whose same hubristic desire for control
led to their downfall what eventually
sets 616 strange apart is that he's able
to sacrifice this desire for control
namely over whether his lived experience
matches up with his ideal vision for
things it might also help that 616
strange in 838 christine got flirty as
hell he's eventually able to cede
control to america when he realizes he
can't defeat wanda and for once he needs
to give the proverbial knife to someone
else meanwhile america has the opposite
experience initially she feels like she
has no control over her powers her
reality and even whether she'll ever see
her moms again by the end she realizes
that even if she can't control what's
happening around her she can learn to
control herself and her powers this is
pretty meaningful existentialists
believe that while we have no control
over the conditions in which we exist we
do have responsibility for ourselves and
our own actions for better or worse this
is why for jean-paul sartre
responsibility is a direct effect of our
existential freedom this tension between
control and lack thereof between wanting
to live in the ideal world and accepting
that we live in the real messy complex
world is nothing new it's been essential
to western philosophy ever since some
greeks and ancient birkenstocks invented
it descartes thought that math with a
side of god made existence into a nice
rational structure where everything
makes sense and you know you exist
because you're thinking about existing
this made reality something that was
understandable with a level of
mathematical certainty david hume on the
other hand thought that this was dumb
and all of our knowledge is based on
lived experience what we see is more
important than what we think kant sort
of mix these two together to argue that
reality does have a formal structure and
while we can't see the causes for
everything we can know some limited
stuff about how the world works for
example we can know some of the
fundamental principles of things like
morality and truth without seeing inside
the mind of god but my debt lord
kierkegaard on the other hand was
interested in how all these attempts at
knowledge affect us at the individual
level in our actual existence and as he
saw it this fundamental tension between
the ideal world and the real world or
ideality in actuality can lead to
despair like the young man in berlin or
the scarlet witch who wants to be a mom
we all have experienced a contradiction
between how we want our world to be and
how our world actually is and as strange
wanda and america learn kierkegaard
thinks the way out of this despair is
making decisions and these decisions
always involve an element of risk or
faith because there is no way of being
certain that your idea is going to be
actualized doctor strange must decide to
give control to america and not insist
on holding the knife or the spooky book
of evil spells wanda needs to decide
that her plan is evil and that to start
writing her wrongs she needs to destroy
the darkhold and seemingly herself
meanwhile america decides that she's
capable of controlling her power and
this decision is accompanied by the
faith that she'll be able to do so it
should also be no surprise that
kierkegaard famously emphasized the
importance of the leap of faith the
paradox of all of this is that there is
power in giving up control and that the
most heroic acts in the film are
precisely those decisions to cede power
for the sake of doing what's right we
can't force our lives to look like the
past but we can decide to live
differently in the future the drive for
repetition and control can be a prison
and the way out is deciding to give up
control and have faith that the future
can still work out even if you can't be
certain about it but what do you guys
think can doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness teach us a thing
or two about accepting that we're not in
control of everything or should we all
search for a secret book of evil magic
so we can make our crush like us let us
know what you think in the comments big
thanks to our patrons for all your
support and if you haven't checked out
our patreon page in a while do it we're
making lots of great new content and
remember to check out our new live
stream wisecrack live every thursday
right here on youtube hit the subscribe
button like you're punching a hole into
the universe where tacos are free and
the big bang theory never made it past
its pilot episode and don't forget to
ring that bell and as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you